foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your money
your work your life all of it I'm your
host John deloney and I'm joined here by
one of my best friends in the history of
my life George Campbell the greatest
humans you can ever meet and we're
taking your calls on life money
everything triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five five two two five give us
a shout it's a rainy day here in
Nashville and we are of a packed house
man it's good to see everybody and look
at the sunshine today John they are
bringing bringing the sunshine
what a great way to start the show
George thanks best friend
you're welcome bester friend let's go to
Alex in New York New York New York New
York what's up Alex
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
call you got it man what's happening
hi so I am currently in 24 000 of bet
and I just lost my job ah man what were
you doing
I have been working as a server in
Barista
um additionally I am an actor I am
currently in school so a lot of my jobs
like what we call survival jobs are in
the service industry excellent so is
there a chance that losing your job has
set you free
yeah I mean the the I mean yeah in terms
of like the place I was at it was
um poorly managed and whatnot which also
gives me opportunity to move forward but
it does put me back behind quite a bit
um my wife is also affected by the
ongoing writers strike right now so I'm
just trying to do my part as her husband
to also like be there for her especially
when it comes to financial needs but I'm
just falling behind sure what kind of
debt is this
um a lot of it is credit cards and I
just I've been listening to your other
show for quite a while now to get me
some inspiration because
um I've been putting myself in this
position a couple times now um in terms
of credit card debt and consolidation
loans and now like I've had enough like
I'm ready to tackle it I am motivated to
destroy it and um I'm ready to take on
three four or five jobs in Gig work to
start
um uh knocking it away good because
that's what needs to happen number one
we gotta quit borrowing money and that
means cutting up the cards and that
means we're not going to start looking
for shortcuts we're going to look in the
mirror and go if I had no other option
other than to make money what would I do
and that's going to be a great start for
you you're already there because you're
angry at this situation what we need to
focus on right now is you guys are in
storm mode we got to cover the bills
your wife has no income coming in right
now or she still have something
she's she's about to start nannying for
the time being until this whole thing's
resolved
um it's just hard to say when the last
one was 100 days this one could be
longer hopefully not I think I think
this one's gonna be longer Alex
personally let's pretend it's going to
be a few months
absolutely and so what do you need to
cover your food utilities housing
Transportation have you figured out what
those expenses are
yeah yeah so my wife is supporting me as
well with my debt Journey so she hears
me talk about the rice and beans the
beans and rice quite a bit oh hold on
are you you're saying she's supporting
your journey is this not y'all's Journey
as a couple
it's
she said we support each other of course
a lot of this vet is just strictly mine
um for my bad habits that again I've had
the realization that like I want to
destroy those as well I'll just spend
spend spend well I'm wondering if this
process would speed up exponentially if
you guys decided this is our debt we're
going to tackle this as a team it's not
Alex's debt it's our debt and I
understand that it's it's his fault but
it's all responsibility now as a couple
have you had that conversation with her
we have not
have not me being me I've
I've tried to keep her out of it but um
that's you know actually something that
I'd be willing to explore as well good I
think we've got to let go of the shame
and guilty yeah before the weekend is
over Alex
I want you to take her out to a
breakfast that y'all probably can't this
can be the last meal out you have for a
long time
it has to be something cheap
and I want you to look across a small
bistro table there in New York and tell
her I'm sorry and I'm inviting you into
this process
and I've tried to be something that I'm
not
and I've tried to duct tape and
and and tie this thing together with
baling wire to make it all work and it's
not and this is me surrendering and
saying let's make this an us thing and I
would be willing to bet
that she will weep with joy that finally
her husband is saying let's really be
married for the first time
uh
yeah I can feel that okay
um amazing here's what we're gonna do
I'm gonna we're gonna give you Financial
Peace University I'm gonna give it to
you but you have to promise that you and
her will sit down on the couch and watch
these lessons y'all aren't doing
anything else that was a low dig but
that was kind of funny you all watch
these videos together Fair
absolutely yes also going to give you
both every dollar app the best app there
is when it comes to finding stuff so
y'all can start tracking this stuff and
when you spin something she's gonna know
cause it's gonna show up on her phone
too okay
okay but here's the big thing
have you reached the point and I I've
grown up with actors or some of my
closest friends have you gotten to the
point where you're ready to put acting
on the background and go get a real job
I say real job but stop pretending after
year five and six and seven and eight
that one day this thing's gonna happen
because here's the deal one day it might
happen but it probably won't yeah it's
both and right
yeah absolutely um and for every John
Kaczynski story like I I was I was my
last job I was going home and then I got
the call to be on the office for every
one of those there's a whole bunch of
people who really went in went all in
and didn't work out and that's great and
it's awesome they went for it what are
you gonna do next that's the question
you have to answer so you're in school
what are you studying
um I am studying acting actually
um it's a two-year Conservatory program
how much is that one of my
it's 750 a month and then with the work
study hours that I put in there it
usually takes me down to about 200 a
month now
who's paying for that
paying for the school yep
uh me okay
are you running up putting there on a
credit card are you actually paying for
it
no so basically what I've been doing is
basically keeping my head above water
with all of my debt and then putting
rent and school payments as priority
okay so Alex when we gift you every
dollar here's what I want you to do open
that up you're going to list out your
income for the month that might not be a
lot this month and then you're gonna
list out your expenses and there's a
paycheck planning tool inside of the
premium version we're going to give you
and you can lay out all of those bills
and you're going to see when the money's
gonna run out and so you've got to make
some decisions on what needs to go of
course the four walls is first you're
pausing the baby steps right now we're
not going to be able to pay extra on the
debt we're just going to pay minimum
payments but once we have enough income
in the door we're going to start paying
them off smallest to largest balance
regardless of the interest rate and once
you get your income back up your wife
gets her income up you're gonna be able
to knock out this 24K in debt and it'll
be in the rear view mirror
yeah but this is going to be a tough
season man like you mentioned four or
five jobs for both of you while we
figure this thing out and get rid of
this debt by Sunday
I want you both to have more than one
job and everybody's leaving New York I
just saw the real estate number
everybody's leaving there's gonna be
plenty of jobs take the first couple of
jobs you can get and over the next few
months work your way up to a couple more
dollars an hour here and there but you
got to work like crazy work like crazy
work like crazy this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm John deloney
with the greatest guy who's ever lived
George Campbell and we are taking your
calls Triple eight eight two five five
two two five we're live talking about
money mental health relationships work
whatever you got going on and listen you
all loved the first edition of our
questions for humans conversation
starter car so much
yeah
George I remember Dave in a meeting
saying we're not doing these these
you're a small ball no one what are we
doing
and he's like I got in this thing to
change lives and you're here with a deck
of cards you hear the deck of cards and
if the worst Magician of all time now
he's like hey man you can make some more
you're gonna make some more
well it's because people loved him yeah
they blew up it's been wild listening to
grandparents talked to the grandkid for
the first time moms and dads talk to
their middle schoolers for the first
it's been couples talking to each other
for the first time excellent so listen
we ran them back and we went back to the
drawing board and came up with even more
fun sometimes ridiculous sometimes
really deep and insightful questions
that make it easier for people to
connect the new additions are ready for
the real world we've got all new friends
parents and kids and couples decks so
you won't be running out of things to
talk about anytime soon and what's
better than some real-time questions
with my friend George Campbell
um all right dude George I got a
question for you okay
um what's the worst physical pain that
you've ever felt oh man you know I try
to avoid pain like all costs but I'll
tell you something's real hard one time
no second grade I cut my thumb opening a
Kool-Aid six-pack those Jammers with a
razor blade a box cutter and I just
sliced right down my thumb
and what hurt more than the slice was
the stitches I got I cried like a baby
it was so painful and I still I still
can't do a thumbs up to this day I want
to hug you a little bit you've never
said that before I have how about you I
feel like you've experienced a lot of
pain I have um I I trained him in May
for years I got knocked out I kept my
shins like literally punched in the face
yeah it's gotta hurt can I tell you the
worst pain I can remember other than
tooth pain like I've got a bunch of I've
got a gummy candy issue and so I've got
a bunch of roots real dude yeah those
nerves I've built some second homes for
some dentists
um
this is embarrassing but one time I was
with a group of kids I was a a sponsor
at a youth event and they were out at
the beach and I just went sprinting and
screaming like an idiot into the beach I
was waving my arms over my head and
somebody had put a railroad
track like a long piece of metal and I
ran in and I kicked it
and my third toe exploded and I remember
I was in the ER I was yelling so loud it
hurt George it hurt in a way that I
couldn't understand when you get knocked
out your whole body absorbed like you're
just out yeah you break an arm or
something it
it was so so isolated and so painful and
I remember being so embarrassed that my
toe hurts so bad
um but that's it man that's the one
that's coming to mind that's strong it's
embarrassing but such it is one of the
other cards in these Stacks is
interesting what do you wish they made a
vending machine for oh man
I haven't even been to a vending machine
since I can remember
yeah but you've got that cigarette
vending machine oh that's right in my
house yeah in your house
um I think it would be cool
um I think working here especially with
James as the producer we don't get a lot
of positive feedback very often so I
think a vending machine where I could
put in a couple of dollars and just pull
out like a happy message wow I think
that would be great that's sad it's kind
of dark but I'm actually a good idea I
think that'd be good I was gonna go with
like puppies
wow I just thought it'd be fun to just
see a bunch of cute puppies and just all
the mental health professionals in
America just went yes with guys like you
were always that's the kind of
conversations this will spark it's a lot
of judgment amongst your friends a lot
of laughter and a lot of memories and
good times too and so uh these are more
than just great conversation starters so
let's be real it's hard for people to
have face-to-face conversations to
connect and where in a way that's not
weird or forced and these cards help
take some of the pressure off and helps
people do that that's right so all
second edition questions for humans
cards are on sale today and George we
mentioned this uh yesterday nothing is
better than being on commission and
having Dave say hey we're gonna offer
all of your products at half price but
they're on sale for 10 bucks they never
have been 10 bucks go to
ramseysolutions.com
store that's ramseysolutions.com store
all right let's go out to Nick in Denver
Colorado what's up Nick how we doing
brother
I'm doing great guys thanks for taking
my call you got it man what's happening
um here's what's going on guys I live in
uh I live in a house it was built in
1913 originally and it's proven to be a
bit of a money pet
and what does that mean you know my wife
and I say again what does that mean you
know just a few months ago bathroom
tiles were starting to fall off of our
wall and our fence our fence is hanging
on by a thread I think if I sneeze too
loud it's going to fall down to the
ground
yeah we've got gutter problems where
they they leak in certain areas and you
know currently I have I have buckets
over there just been hesitant to spend
money the things things like that
um and so and so that's it we're just
trying to figure out you know should we
stay here should we move if we move and
try to follow the the guidelines it's
going to be tough in our area
um we're currently on a 30 year and
dropping it down to a 15. could just
prove difficult and so we're just trying
to figure out our next move should we
rent do we stay here and try to cash
flow some repairs
how much money do you guys have in the
bank
one baby step three so we probably have
18 18 Grand in the bank right now and
that's almost a fully funded emergency
fund okay I'm sure it keeps getting
drained because of these home repairs
yep we just rated the bathroom recently
it was uh 15 grand and while doing you
know baby steps two and three is what
was going on at the time we cash flowed
that well I'm proud of you guys for
making it this far what's the house
worth as is if you sold today what do
you think you could get for it
yeah trying to trying to guess what an
inspection might spit out and what a
buyer might buy I bet you we walk out of
here with 180 in cash
after you're saying that's your net
profit
that'd be net profit sellers fees any
any type of things that pop up in the
inspection I bet you we still walk out
with 180. Okay so let's call that the
down payment on another home would that
allow you guys to move into something
comparable that's less of a headache
no it really wouldn't our interest rate
now is four in the low fours and rates
are floating higher than that and so
even just to get an equivalently priced
house our payment would go up so
actually uh we break the rules out of
15. so what if you could pause start to
do some of these repairs get by for
another year or two while you save up
and then move out when you have enough
money to where you've got the repairs
you've got the equity you can roll that
over to the next one on a 15 year and
have it make sense and you can always
refinance later to get your rates lower
yeah would that be a good in between
I think so and it feels kind of like a
baby step 3B except instead of a down
payment it's going kind of into the
house which would probably help us on
our next down payment do you hate this
house
oh God uh the answer to that is
definitely yes but also
um I think we realized that at similar
prices we're not going to find uh much
better you know we have three kids and
so desire to have multiple bedrooms and
bathrooms and the prices just go up in
our area so that's what I was getting at
here's what I've been guilty of I don't
want to put my world on to you but
here's what I've been guilty of I've
been guilty of
hating a car and I just I grow to hate
it more and more and more or I had one
particular house I'm thinking of I I
just I just grew to not like it
and as the great brene Brown says what
you go looking for in the world you are
sure to find
so I began to see every single thing
that was wrong with it
and then I start casting out five years
from now and ten years from now I'm
gonna have to replace this and fix this
and I end up almost
casting this Vision upon this place that
isn't actually accurate now I'm not
saying you don't need repairs and I'm
not saying that your fence isn't
embarrassing all that stuff's true
but have you just begun to mash down on
this house when really some of the
challenge challenges are you got three
kids and life got really chaotic and you
and your wife haven't re redesigned your
marriage yet to accommodate three kids
you're starting to still trying to live
one kid marriage or your job's crazy or
you're just nervous about the economy
see what I'm saying how we cast all of
this other drama onto one thing we just
make it so so wild so here's my
challenge my challenge would be for you
and your wife to go out somewhere out of
the house and sit down and talk to each
other
and just cast a vision vision for this
house what do we have to do to make this
thing habitable you got to fix the leaks
you get that kind of stuff what could we
get by with for the next 24 36 months
would we be willing to do that
could we live in this five more years
and if so just pay the stupid thing off
and and crash there for a while or if
it's got to go then you gotta go but
let's sit down and be intentional about
it and don't just get so mad you do
something rash this is the Ramsay show
we'll be right back
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I'm John deloney joined here by
George Campbell and we are taking your
calls on money marriage relationships
mental health work whatever you got
going on we probably got an opinion on
it give us a shout triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go out
to Anthony in detail in Dallas Texas
what's up Anthony
yes how you guys doing we're doing
fantastic man what's happening
I just had a quick question for you I'm
a combat vector and struggling if I
should take a student loan discharge or
not just wanted to kind of get your
advice and your opinion on it
tell me what your tell me a little bit
more about what are you with a program
are they looking to are they going to
cancel your loans out tell me what
you're talking about
yeah exactly so just due to my time in
Iraq and Afghanistan uh and my VA rating
if you have a certain rating uh they
completely forgive your federal student
loans and I currently have about a
hundred and ten thousand dollars worth
of
I would take that right now
what what's your hesitation
well part of me I mean it depends on the
day part of me feels like it's a benefit
I earned take it and just you know move
forward but then the other side I guess
being what I did in the military I'm all
about alternate responsibility and I
feel like it's my loan I signed for it
so I should kind of Honor that signature
I agree with that but I uh so that's
something I tell everybody you put your
name on a piece of paper be a person of
Integrity but you also put your name on
a piece of paper and that was part of
the benefits package you accepted when
you decided I'm going to put my life on
the line for the deloney family
gotcha so what I will say as a taxpayer
I'm happy to participate in discharging
this for you
okay okay it's an honor for me and my
family to pitch in and help you have the
next chapter of your life how about that
well much appreciated yeah it's just
been a struggle for a while so I got it
you know let me give a call and kind of
get some advice well I mean you're a
person of high high integrity right now
if you were somebody who just kept going
to school and going to school and I just
wanna I don't know I'd have a different
story I would tell you you put your name
on a piece of paper but you did you
signed a loan and you also signed up for
something that part of the agreement was
we're gonna pay for this when it's over
got you see what I'm saying George what
do you think I'm fully with am I out to
lunch no I mean this is something that
he has earned it's not something that he
feels entitled to and if he wants to pay
it forward man you go be super generous
for the rest of your life because of
this and so I'm gonna accept Grace when
it is given you know in terms like this
where it's part of a benefits package
there's nothing wrong with taking
advantage of that especially when it
propels you in your financial Journey
won't it Anthony
oh definitely how many years would you
spend just trying to pay this off
getting by as a combat vet
no sure probably about four or five easy
what's your degree in
uh it's a masters an MBA in finance
will you please do good with that
it's like you just got out of Hogwarts
with one of those little stick wands and
you can just be mean or you can help
people will you be a good MBA
you know actually I'm kind of switching
fields and uh going into the healthcare
industry just to kind of help other
people deal with some of the things I
have to deal with but I can use that uh
to help them in other words absolutely
excellent excellent yeah I mean I'm I'm
fully supportive of you brother I'm I'm
I'm grateful uh for you and like I said
the deloni family is happy to pitch in
um and I like George I like what you
said man
um sometimes
I don't call it survivor's guilt because
that's not what it is but there's a
sense of I see all these people
struggling around me and and I got this
get out of jail free card but it's not
even that I earned it right I earned it
um but I feel weird about taking it and
so I like the if you still have that
sense of
take the agreement that you shook hands
on right and Pay It Forward right go
find somebody who's just enrolled in
enlisting who's not um going to have
this rating and say I'll help you out a
semester because that's somebody help me
I'm gonna help you like you can do do
whatever you want to whatever your
conscience and your finances allow but
um I do like that I like paying it
forward that way that's pretty cool man
all right let's run out to Jessica in
Orlando what's up Jessica how we doing
standing uh we're up against a clock so
hop to it what uh what you got going on
so um my husband and I are thinking
about taking out a HELOC to extend our
home and I listened to you guys long
enough to know that he was probably
screaming no right now internally I
literally stopped myself from
interrupting you I was trying to hear
you out so so let me just try to get
through this super quick so we um we owe
280 000 on our home and we have 10 acres
of land and right now with the way the
market is
um if we were to sell this and make four
or five hundred thousand off of it that
is what 10 acres alone is going for and
the price to build is up to 165 a square
foot right now so it would cost us
almost double what it would cost for us
to take some of the equity out and make
our home bigger we now have three
children and we've significantly
outgrown the size of our home so in the
end
our mortgage payment what we would owe
would be almost half of what it would
look like if we did the reverse where we
sold it and tried to build on 10 acres
somewhere so you have backed yourself
into a very tight either or corner okay
give me a third option
so a third option I I know another thing
I thought about as if we were to go
further you know outside of where we
currently live the problem is my
husband's in law enforcement and he has
to live within a certain mile radius
from where he works because of his work
hard that's just like 1B give me a third
option
I'll give you one because I'm going
through the exact same thing right now I
live on some acreage outside of town and
it was incredible and we loved it and
then my wife was like man you know what
I don't like taking an hour to get to
the grocery store and so now we're
having that conversation the third
option might be what if we rode this out
for 24 months or 28 months and we came
up with a plan to pay for X of this
thing up front so we don't have to sell
this place
what you're doing is you're trying to
call justify buying something that you
can't afford
or you're trying to say if we don't do
this and we have to sell everything and
burn our dreams to the ground I just
don't think either one of those things
is the either or
um how big is this house
um it's just under 2 000 square feet
okay and there's five of you running
around having fun
they do so I hear you and you're right
um you know when I think about it
because we paid about 65 000 off in the
last two years my husband and I each
took on extra jobs and we've been very
aggressive with that so we're completely
debt free we have our emergency funds
set awesome and so I I know it's
something we probably could Fund in a
few years it's more my son just turned
13 and now I feel like I'm running out
of time so I have to do this for him now
your son is living my son's 13. our two
boys are
living outside of the Matrix right now
because they get to wake up and go
outside and work outside and mow grass
and listen to trees and see deer they're
having different lives and kids that are
running up and down streets with screens
and all that stuff
right so whatever you think you need to
rescue him from I want to put you at
ease you don't
if you want a different kind of life you
know that's all that's all well and good
but
um you're not abandoning or destroying
your kid's life I'd love to see you buy
your husband a shop which is probably
what this is all about get him a shop
out back or get yourself a shop out back
for about 50 000 bucks and be able to
just smile all the way through it
right the other piece of this equation
Jessica is helocs are going to put your
home at risk
right there's a variable interest rate
and it doesn't create any cash flow and
so I would pause if you really want to
stay here we're going to pause in cash
flow as quickly as we can to do these
renovations if you can't wait you need
to sell the home and need to find
something in the area that you can all
fit in comfortably and it might mean
compromises
but either way the HELOC is not going to
be the Saving Grace here can I put a can
I say something hard
yeah absolutely
um my dad's police officer I grew up in
that home and your husband's in law
enforcement you you live in that home
my dad your husband they were one
incident away from getting put on
disability from having to fight the city
or the municipality or the county for
disability check man that's a high risk
job to put your house on the Block
for an add-on I just wouldn't do it
especially in that kind of high risk
field that your your husband and my dad
are in this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined by George Campbell and we're
taking your calls on money life mental
health marriage whatever's going on
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five it's triple eight eight two five
five two two five listen if you're a new
listener and you want to dive deeper
into the Ramsay baby steps if you're
listening to this thing you've been
watching some clips on YouTube or the
tick tocks Dave is a tick tock sensation
now I wish that was a joke but he
actually went viral and it was inside
like Atomic viral like Elon Musk is
replying to the tweets it's pretty wild
if there's it I I think that's actually
like China was like oh this will be
funny for us I I mean I really do think
it was like a national Flex they're
trolling Dave it's like giving him to
the algorithms he's like oh you can talk
about about Tick Tock we're gonna make
you Tick Tock there's 30 million views
on a video that's seven years old but
listen if you were catching us on tick
tock on Instagram on YouTube wherever
you find us and you're wondering what is
all this financial piece lingo what is
all this baby steps nonsense what is
what are y'all doing
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
the get started button we're going to
help you figure out the best next step
for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today okay go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started we're going to answer all your
questions we know it can be like just
wandering into the wrong door and
suddenly you're in a big cult meeting
it's what it feels like I know that's
what it feels like go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on get
started and we will walk you through it
all and it is amazing all right let's go
to Deborah in Tampa Florida what's up
Deborah
hi there how are you doing John hi
George thank you so much for taking my
call of course how are you very excited
I promise we're more excited and uh
thank you well anyway I am 59 and single
I have not saved anything for retirement
when you say anything do you mean
literally zero
um I have eighteen hundred dollars in
the Deferred
Compensation and I work for the state so
I'll have a pension of about fifteen
hundred dollars if I retire when I'm 67.
okay
and I wanted to start uh Ross I hear you
talking about starting a Roth IRA uh the
way that we do it in the baby steps
except I paid off my house instead of
starting the retirement okay excited
started listening to you and started
paying off the house and I did that so
I'm in no debt and paid off the house
good question do I the Deferred
Compensation that I have at work which
is just pre-tax I haven't found any of
the Investments that look like it
matches what you guys suggest so I
didn't know if there was something else
that I should open up besides one Roth
IRA
what are your other options currently
for retirement
do you have any I don't have anything
else that work okay
so outside of that you do have do you
have a health insurance plan
uh yes but slow I haven't I I'm not
eligible for the HSN okay not eligible
for the HSA so your other option would
be a taxable brokerage account outside
of retirement if you don't have any tax
advantage retirement options no HSA and
you do have the Roth IRA you can
contribute to which you do have ketchup
contributions because you're over 50
which will help it's not going to like
change the game but it might mean we
work a little bit longer than we wanted
to and we throw a lot more than we are
comfortable with towards investing but
you should have tons of margins because
you don't have a mortgage payment you
have no debt what's your income so I
actually I actually have I can do this
the 625 dollars a month to throw you
know for the 7 500 to catch up on the
Roth for the other account should I so I
should open I shouldn't open a a
traditional Ross or do the Deferred Comp
even though I don't like the options to
invest
um I still have about another I'd say
500 a month I can put in that account
okay I'm living off of I'm being very
frugal good well the math on the Roth
versus traditional at your age it may
kind of be a wash at this point but I
still like the idea of whatever's in
that account is what you get and you've
already paid taxes on it you know 10
years down the line so do you have a
plan on when you want to stop working or
able to
is it 67 he said and I really don't want
to go past 67. okay because here's what
you can do see let's see where we're at
at 67 with our investments our pension
our expenses at that point and if you're
able to retire comfortably then we can
go all right we're good we've got enough
to make it but this is going to be
tighter I mean you're going to be able
to retire with dignity but it may not be
all the luxuries you once dreamed of
sure and so I would do you have a
financial advisor currently
uh no I don't I think we need to put
some of this on paper and crunch some
actual numbers number one to give us
some reality but also to give us some
hope
because you'd be shocked at what
compound interest can do for 10 years
when you're really focused
and that might be a mix of the Roth IRA
maxing that out ketchup contributions
taxable brokerage account on top of
building up your savings and have a few
different buckets you can pull from in
retirement
yes because you guys motivated me so
much I just want to tell you last year I
was making Thirty one thousand dollars
and now I'm making 42 and I think I'm
gonna get a five percent raise in
another month what do you do what do you
do for work I went for a promotion to
try to get out of the situation that I
was in and I was able to pay my house
off with a difference I'm still living
on what I was making prior to the raises
that is awesome awesome Deborah I want
you to make me and Georgia yeah you guys
I wouldn't be doing that well we just
run our miles on the radio you are the
one actually out there doing the work so
listen I want you to make me and Georgia
promise
okay see I promise
I promise
I can't tell you how many folks I've
talked to between the age of 59 and 70.
who just decide I'm gonna retire
almost like that scene in the office
when Michael Scott goes out and declares
bankruptcy
the number of times someone's told me
they're gonna retire next year they're
going to retire at this age and I ask
the question can you afford to retire
they look at me as though that question
has never crossed their mind they don't
know and so I want there to be nobody on
planet Earth who knows the insides and
outs of your financial situation better
than Debra
I want you to know to the dollar to the
ten dollars
how how much time this is going to take
you if the market does X what fund I
should put this in and that's why you
got to sit down with a smart investor
Pro go to ramseysolutions.com
smartbester Pro I want you to go talk to
those folks because they're going to
walk you through and they're going to
more importantly they're gonna teach you
how and why your money is doing what
it's doing and then you're gonna have to
deal in reality you may really want to
be done at 67 you may be exhausted but
you may have to go till 71 because
that's what then that's just math right
but I want you to take ownership of this
thing you've been avoiding it for a long
long time because it's scary let's just
take this sucker by the horns is that
fair
yes it is all right we are super proud
of you proud of you Deborah you're
killing it
thank you awesome awesome awesome
George I I
you know last time we we co-hosted the
show together we took a couple of calls
about how do I get that uh passive
income oh yeah that was those are my
favorite or hey I think I'm gonna retire
as though you can just wish it and these
are sign up sheets yeah yeah yeah it's a
big problem it is and as somebody who
has spent like I spent especially my
younger years I spent a lot of time
avoiding these numbers because I didn't
understand them and when I don't
understand things that makes me anxious
and so I just avoid it
man when I'm having these conversations
with 59 60 65 year olds seven-year-olds
it's both heartbreaking and scary
because you realize oh you you don't
understand like you don't just walk
outside and be like I retire and money
shows up you just quit working and then
the paycheck stop right and some of them
are heartbreaking now luckily Deborah's
in a much better spot than most people
who have nothing in retirement because
she has a paid for a house but when
someone calls in they're in their 20s
they're doing dumb that's fine you got a
lot of time to make up for that thanks
to compound growth when you're 16 you
want to retire two years from now that's
a problem when you have nothing saved
and so the best time to plant the tree
was 30 years ago the next best time is
today and so I'm glad Deborah's taking
the steps to do what she can to have a
somewhat dignified retirement but please
do not depend on social security or your
pension to float you by as we've seen
last few years inflation is a beast and
life just keeps getting more and more
expensive and we want to do more and
more stuff as we get closer to
retirement and that doesn't happen
without a plan and diligence and
consistency over a long period of time
and as we see in these debt ceiling
fights these kids and the
sandbox throwing crayons at each other
not solving any real problems man Social
Security man it is on a on a on a thin
thread my friend
thread hey I want to thank you George
great job I want to thank the gang in
the booth I want to thank you America
listen let's build a non-acious life pay
off your debts get connected to a
community give recklessly and seek peace
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money I'm John deloney joined here by
George Campbell and we are taking your
calls on just about anything money your
retirement your mental health your
marriage parenting whatever you got
going on the nonsense going on in
schools whatever is on your heart and
mind give us a shout triple eight eight
two five five two two five it's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in Georgia not George we were just
talking off air
I know this is going to date the show
but listen it's Friday
you got two days till Mother's Day two
days if you're listening to this live I
hope your heart just stopped get on the
phone make it happen and if you're
listening to this while you're mowing
the lawn on Saturday you've got less
than 24 hours make it happen don't phone
it in don't do something special it's
Mother's Day for crying out loud all
right let's go out to Catherine and
Santa Fe New Mexico one of my favorite
places in the world what's up Catherine
hi John I'm George thank you for taking
my call uh one question
um my husband and I have been out of
work since September last year and um we
it's getting a little tight right now
and so we called our creditors to
um be proactive and ask them to can we
be on a program paying less over a
period of time we've had two that will
not work with us what can we do
I'm so confused you're telling me for
nine months there was Zero jobs that
would hire you guys in the single
hottest job market in the history of U.S
of the United States I just don't buy it
Catherine I really want to believe you
how what happened
hey I called for advice not to be get
given a value well the advice is go to
work and you're telling me you can't
work what's what I had a car accident
two years ago oh yeah I had a car
accident two years ago I'm not able to
and that's as far as I'll go there okay
and my husband's in the tech industry
um and there's millions of people that
have been laid off in all of those
Industries uh he's looking for work
outside of his industry but I'm just
asking you what what would be possible
is are there any
um rules or laws or or considerations
for for a company uh that you owe money
to a credit card so on that will not
um that will not allow you to make
arrangements no they I mean they they
make arrangements when they think
they're not going to get paid and they
start to grasp what they've got what
they'll take what they can get
but they'll also sue you
because we have every intention to pay
right along but of course but but
they're they're going to be thinking so
here's the deal
um they're going to be thinking the
exact same thing that George and I just
thought
and so I know there's going to be
extenuating circumstances there's going
to be hey what about this what about
this but their first question is going
to be our first question which is hey
George and I both have families if we
get laid off in our sector and there's
no job I'm going to start mowing lawns
and I'm gonna start driving for Uber and
I'm gonna start driving for Amazon I
know you can't do that because you've
got some some
outside of the bell curve challenges but
what I'm saying is man they're just
going to say Hey you signed up for to
borrow money from us and you said you'd
pay us back in these time and waiting
for you to pay us back so I don't know
of any legal requirements for any
creditors to work with you outside of
like these special mandates like uh the
government made during covet
um like they can't evict you or they
can't do X Y and Z I don't know of
anything like that
I mean there's some things I can't do
legally like call you outside of certain
hours harass you things like that but
they're legally allowed to collect the
money and they can sue you for that
money and so you can tell them I'd be
proactive with them and say listen we
have no income right now we'd love to
pay you something we can't do that right
now how bad is the debt situation
um well we owe about 60 000 in debt and
uh or with various
companies including you know your car
payment and so on um and uh we're not
one to just buy buy we only have one car
at this point after the accident we did
not replace my car did they write you a
job
they paid off a loan they did not it did
not cover our down that we paid on the
car okay um but it did cover up it did
Cover the loan uh so so so that was good
and we're renting and uh uh we started
something on the side here trying to be
proactive but my husband you know had a
really great job
um in his sector and I think age is part
of it uh he's 65 and that plays a role
and there's all these um he interviews
really well he gets right to the top and
we think the Bean Counter says oh you
know there's a lot of people out there
to choose from so
um so we are being proactive and we have
put things in place to create something
on our own
um I was just wondering if they're you
know if there's something you could say
to a creditors you know hey and we keep
saying we fully intend to pay we just
would like to pay a little less for you
know like four or five months or
something that's what we're asking yeah
if you've called and made that call and
asked them to work because I mean what
you're doing is you're appealing to
Grace will you please help us out and
they said yes they said no we won't help
you out and every one of them is going
to say well just don't pay the others
you pay us
and then the next one's going to say
well I don't care about your car payment
your whatever payment you pay me because
I loaned you money and right so yeah
it's just going to go around it's going
to go around and around like that
um how short are you do you have any
income coming in whatsoever
Social Security okay
how much is that a month so we're we're
a couple thousand dollars short a month
how much is that Social Security every
month
so how are you covering the difference 4
500 4 500. okay and your expenses are
more than that
um our house which is a rental is 2500 a
month
is there anywhere cheaper you can move
in this area
uh like a way like not in the Santa Fe
area
well we
[Music]
um
let me rephrase that you can't afford to
live in Santa Fe yeah it is eating up
too much of the little income you guys
have right now and it's going to be
super hard to pay off debt when you know
60 70 of your income is going towards
housing here's my big fear Catherine is
that they're gonna come take your your
one car away
they're gonna repo it no we're not late
on anything yet do you have other deaths
outside of the collections
um we're we're not in trouble yet we're
just trying to make arrangements and and
we and we know you know because we at
this point we we were really hoping with
all these interviews that you got so far
with each one sure that we would have a
job at any time you know and that was
that's been since September so it's
become you know evident we have to do
something now can you guys can he go
drive for ubereats doordash deliver for
Amazon do anything
he's applied
for
those
um he's applied as a customer service
person at a at a Best Buy in etc etc for
nine months no one has hired him I just
can't believe that in this job market
yeah even for the side gig economy
well there's so many people that are out
of work we thought it wouldn't be an
issue and so when when he said when my
husband said well I'm going to go
outside of my my industry I'm going to
have to go outside of my industry and
and he's he's not buying steady for
multiple jobs a day anything that comes
up and he's not in and he's gotten
interviews and he even applies for a
manager at Billard you know anything at
all that he could do is I would that
would just sustain us for this period of
time well he's it sounds like he's Noble
he's he's going down swinging I think as
George said the harder conversation is
because it may be that Santa Fe that
work is really tight right now but it's
bananas in other markets it may be time
to have a really hard conversation about
we can't afford to live here right now
and there is no work
thank you
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what is up this is the Ramsey Show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I'm John deloney joined by George
Campbell we're taking your calls on life
and money and relationships mental
health whatever you got going on listen
if you're planning a move sometime soon
that's fantastic I'm excited for you but
I gotta be honest as well in most places
around the country you'll still be
facing high home prices and interest
rates aren't just running back to their
record lows but that doesn't make home
ownership impossible
if you want to buy or sell you've got to
make sure you're financially ready and
you have to have a trusted and
experienced real estate agent to walk
you through it not a family friend who
just got their license last month and
not Bill's Brothers Dan sisters Grandma
who he knows at church who just don't do
it
don't do it don't get with somebody the
real estate is just a part-time hobby
that you don't know you need a pro who's
a true expert in their local market and
knows how to negotiate a strong deal you
can find High Caliber Ramsey trusted
agents like that through our endorsed
local provider program and since we vet
Agents from around the country who have
the best support whether you're moving
from Florida to Alaska or buying your
first home somewhere in between go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent to find a Ramsey trusted real
estate agent today that's
ramseysolutions.com
agent and our question of the day is
brought to you by narrowly your hub for
Home Services here in Tennessee we have
mosquitoes the size of George camel but
neighborly's trusted service Brands like
mosquito Joe help make sure anyone even
in the South can enjoy their backyard
all summer go to neighborly.com to find
providers near you I've been and told
him just as annoying as mosquitoes so
that's a good enough you took that one
I'm just saying they're as big as you
but I think you're much much more lovely
I think it's been a campfire with you
way more than George size mosquito I
appreciate that well today's question
comes from Sandra in New Mexico she asks
we've sold our home of 20 years at a
great profit we currently have a hundred
fifty thousand dollars in the bank
should we take out a construction loan
to build our home and then put down a
great down payment or use our savings
then do a construction loan for the
balance we want to make the smartest
decision we already own the land and
have no other debt
great question so construction loans are
short-term loans that you would use to
build the home they have higher interest
rates and so that's not that's not a fun
part and so if I'm in your shoes I would
take the construction loan now for the
shorter term while the house is being
built and then convert it to the
conventional 15-year fixed with that
great great down payment so you take out
a construction loan to make sure the GC
and the construction company gets paid
and then once you have all shaken hands
this is the home and you move into it
you do you then roll that into or do you
convert what's the conversion process do
you know it would just convert to a
conventional loan okay yeah and I would
stick with the 15-year fix so that's the
big question here there's so many
details we don't know to give you great
advice but make sure that once all this
is said and done that down payment will
get you to the spot where you can do a
15-year fixed rate mortgage where their
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay that will help you
dictate if now is the time to begin this
process and that I'll tell you this
um I had some weird
not quite this many different variables
but when I bought my home this is my
first time buying land and all that when
I called Churchill and they walked me
through it was refinancing it
they started the conversation with we
are not going to take your money if it's
not great for you right and I knew right
then I'm good right so we sat down to
work through all the details what about
this how about this is this the best way
to do it so call on our buddies over at
Churchill getting down with an El
sitting down with an ELP they're gonna
give you the real data and the best part
is they're not going to take advantage
of you right they're gonna do the best
thing for you so there's like you said
there's so many nuances here so many
variables that we don't know the answer
to how big of a house are they trying to
build how long like all that kind of
stuff so yeah sit down with a
Churchill Mortgage person or sit down
with an ELP and walk through all the run
through the numbers yeah I think that's
fantastic all right let's run out to
North Bay Ontario Canada and talk to
Jake Jake what's up Jake
hey how's it going guys we're partying
man what are you up to
good good uh I'll keep it short and
sweet here first time home buyer uh
seller wanted 120k gave him a final
offer of 86.5 he took it I'm looking to
put 40K into my starter home wondering
if it's a good idea whoa they have homes
that cheap in Canada
they do I live uh on the North Point of
Lake Superior in a pretty remote area
but uh they do you can find them if you
work hard enough okay so you landed the
deal at 86.5 do you have the cash for
that or are you taking out a mortgage
I I actually am sitting in the house
right now as we're talking I took out a
mortgage for it okay so what's on the
mortgage
it's uh so it's four percent fixed for
five years over 25 years it's 86.5 I got
a pre- uh pre-purchase Improvement plan
from the lender so my mortgage is for a
hundred and five thousand when I put 22k
worth of Renovations into my home
they'll cut me a check for 22 Grand
whoa that's complicated okay so you
didn't you did an adjustable rate
mortgage
um that's a good question all I know is
it's uh the way you explain that you
said for a certain number of years you
said 20 over five
yeah so 4.8 for five years oh Jake don't
do you got an arm man
okay well the arm is mortgage for you
just got screwed we got you okay go
ahead it means the interest rate is
gonna jack up
so if I'm in your shoes when you could
and when it makes sense financially and
you can Roi on it refinance to a
conventional loan
okay but aside from that you're saying
you want to put another 40 out of your
own money into this house
I do on top of the extra 22. that is
correct okay what's your income
um myself and my girlfriend clear 125
Grand a year oh boy is she on this
mortgage
no she's uh just girlfriend not a wife
so this is all my responsibility is she
is she she's not on the deed either
paying into it though no she she refuses
to not she does give me money uh she
doesn't have to I never asked for it but
right now it's just my house I know but
just know this one day she's gonna go
hey I've been paying into this I paid
for half of this thing and if y'all
break up that's gonna be a mess man here
well we have been together for almost
four years now and and the plan is
marriage down the line I know I know I
know you just eat I I and I don't wanna
I'm not I'm not throwing shade at your
relationship just know that George and I
only have jobs because people end up in
situations that nobody planned for okay
so that our world most of our Lives is
we were together forever and then that's
our that's that's what we deal with all
day every day okay so not throwing shade
at you guys y'all may be great
um
I'm nervous about you
basically doubling
what you have into a house
from what you bought it for
okay meaning you would be you bought it
for 86 which means let's just pretend
that's about what you would sell it for
and you want to put another 60 into it
I do it's the uh it is the only house on
this block that hasn't sold for under
200 if that means anything to you what
was wrong with it
um basically a guy in town bought too
many houses thinking he was going to
rent them out renters went in barely got
any money out of them wrecked the house
a little bit and I came to him with an
offer and he took it how sure are you
that 60 Grand is going to get this thing
in Tip-Top shape and make it a 200 grand
house
I'd say about 95 percent
okay and you're gonna cash flow this
extra 40. that is correct and so this
we're talking over a long period of time
what what's your income
I make 95 clear 95 a year okay do you
have any other debt
I have a uh truck I owe 30 on it and
that's it okay and do you have an
emergency fund
I do about 20 G's in the bank awesome
okay so my A1 before you start
renovating this house is let's get rid
of that truck payment
okay
because right now that is an ankle biter
that's stealing from your ability to
cash flow these Renovations let me tell
you okay like
mathematically I I I mean George and I
can't argue with you if you think it's
going to sell for this or I think it's
worth that or whatever
um I think you're probably
overestimating how much it would sell
for but that's we don't have to debate
that I'm gonna tell you what I would do
in your situation I would take that 40K
I'd pay my car off I'd have 10K I would
start paying that mortgage off as fast
as humanly possible and I would zero
that thing out in 24 to 36 months and
then I would save up that other 60 Grand
and put whatever you want into the house
and use this over the long term man yeah
make it livable for now until you're
completely debt free then we can go Hog
Wild and have some fun that's what I
would do in my own home that's the best
advice I can give you right now we'll be
right back
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
either one
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
forty percent off selected products
visit blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
foreign
Texas and talk to Nathan what's up
brother Nathan how we doing
good how are y'all outstanding man
what's up
uh yeah I just have a question my
company is offering the match three
percent of my salary and put it into a
single IRA and I didn't know if I should
do all 15 into there or 12 into a bra
and do the three percent for this simple
so the simple is a traditional it's not
Roth
yes okay so in that case I would take
the three percent match and then move to
the Roth IRA and then fully fund that
and if you still don't hit 15 you can go
back to the simple IRA
okay okay so the I'll give you the
investing strategy that's easy to
remember match beats Roth beats
traditional so match always comes first
because it's a 100 return Then Roth
because we want to see that money grow
tax-free because we already paid taxes
on it then traditional would be the
third option once you run out of Roth
options
okay so just go ahead and put all 15 of
my salary into the simple well you said
the simple is not Roth
yes correct yes it's not
it's not rock okay so just do up to the
match and then open a Roth IRA if you're
eligible for that and okay awesome Max
that out yeah see what I was asking okay
yeah all right way to go man
yeah thank you thank you absolutely you
got it man let's go out to Washington DC
and talk to John what's up John how we
doing man
how's it going man pretty good pretty
good excellent what's up
I had a question so I'm 19.
um what would you do if you had 100K and
you wanted to invest that and turn that
into a million
by when
25.
you want to make nine hundred thousand
dollars in six years on an investment
well I uh um
is it just uh just a question I'm not
angry I'm just truly wondering so what
was the actual goal there of like I want
to have a million bucks by 26.
so um right now I uh
I work for a company where I sell roofs
through insurance companies and I make a
pretty decent pretty decently uh
I wasn't wondering how can I like uh
start up my own type of situation or
that I can invest in other things and
gain passive income from those with
assets oh okay you've been on The Tick
Tock haven't you
not really I try to avoid social media
ah good for you man good for you so well
I heard the board passive income and
assets and I went okay here we go this
guy's been listening to somebody so this
idea of passive income is actually a
myth it's so much harder than it looks
and almost nobody can actually achieve
it and so if I'm do you actually have a
hundred thousand dollars
I have about 30k right now okay and is
that all the money to your name
uh uh liquid yeah do you have any debt
no
you are crushing it my man 19 years old
with 30 grand no debt this is a great
starting point so I'm gonna call what
how much of that would you call a
six-month emergency fund
all of it all of us in the last six
months but I mean the 30k you would you
say 20K is a fully funded emergency fund
for you
uh what do you mean fully funded
emergency fund three to six months of
expenses if you added what what one
month of expenses are times six
um that would probably be like two three
k i don't really spend much okay so
let's call it 20K is your fully funded
emergency fund you've got 10K to play
around with and then do you have any uh
investing options through your employer
currently
uh no no I don't okay so you're on your
own for investing
yeah so the start the first place I
would go is open a Roth IRA and I would
fully fund that that's going to be about
6 500 bucks
okay so you could do that and the end
goal is start investing 15 of your
income
because we still have other things we've
got to do with our life we've got to go
on vacation we gotta upgrade the car you
want to be a homeowner one day
yeah of course no I'm looking at that
next year so then we got to save up a
down payment so we can't do everything
all at once and so I love 15 as a
starting point because it allows us to
focus on other goals like saving up that
down payment so I love the goal of like
I want to be a millionaire one day but
the idea that I'm going to turn a
hundred thousand into a million six
years from now that tells me you're more
likely to lose it than you are to gain
anything
yeah because most of the strategies
involved to turn money that quickly
involve a lot of risk that I'm not
comfortable with or drugs
you could go to Vegas today and just put
it on black and hope for the best right
hey um so we did
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in North America
and the result of that is Dave Ramsey's
best-selling book baby steps
millionaires hang on the line here I'm
going to send you a free copy of the
book
and I want you to work through it and
also I'm gonna send you his best-selling
book that sold millions and millions of
copies called The Total Money Makeover
and I want you to read them back to back
and here's the thing what you're going
to find in these books is they're very
very simple
and they are also not gimmicky
and you're gonna go are you kidding me
it sounds like I'm talking to like my
great grandma and you are because
nothing in this book is is not common
sense and what George and I have a
ringside seat every day of our life is
people who try to outsmart math
and they try to outsmart common sense
and they end up broke and broke and
broke or they got four rental properties
that they have on adjustable rate
mortgages and they're like I'm cash
flowing baby and they are one frog's
hair from losing everything okay so
here's our goal I want you to be a
multi-multi-millionaire because I want
you to have a great business and be a
great leader and be
obnoxiously generous in your local
community that's who that's the guy that
I want to see before me I need a good
roof for my community like you
but I want you to get there smart I
don't want you to get there slow and I
want you to build wisdom and strength
along the way so hang on the line here
and we'll get you squared up brother
we'll get you taken care of
um let's go out to Joanna in Atlanta
what's up Joanna how we doing
Hi how are you guys doing John and
George awesome hey we are up against the
clock so hop right into your question
okay so I am relocating for a job and I
decided to sell my house but talking to
people they are urging me that I should
rent my question is am I crazy for
wanting to sell my house to get my debt
paid off
where are you moving faster
I'm moving to Dallas Texas
and what are they telling you to do
these people oh like people people
around me they're saying that I should
rent out my house
so they want you to have two mortgages
well I'll be renting when I go to Texas
uh okay how much debt do you have
so
all together with with my house
just Consumer Debt outside of the
mortgage
um about 88 000 between student loan and
my car okay and selling this house will
allow you to be completely debt free
with money left over
yes what profit do you think you'd get
from selling the house
so it's in the process now with like
taxes and fees out of the way it'll be
close to about ninety five thousand
ninety to ninety five thousand awesome
and how much money do you have in the
bank
about three thousand okay so this would
clear your debt and give you a few
thousand bucks left over
yes that's amazing I would do this
tomorrow
okay yeah I don't know why these people
get a vote in your life and the reason
they're telling you it's crazy is
because they're looking at all these
tick tocks and Instagrams going oh my
gosh passive income from rentals is
awesome you know what they're not
thinking about Joanna trying to be a
long-distance landlord from Dallas to
Atlanta and now the HVAC broke and she
doesn't have the money to cover it and
now she's freaking out about how she's
gonna deal with this
sketchy somebody and be like hey you
take care of it they're like yeah and
they just sent somebody over there who
duct taped it the question you need to
ask yourself is you're in Atlanta right
now would you buy a rando rental
property in South Carolina
no no and so if you're if you put
yourself in Dallas and think would I
just buy a random House in Atlanta and
try to manage it along you would never
do that listen in a few months you're
going to be in Dallas Texas and you're
not gonna owe anyone anything you're
gonna build up that emergency fund save
up for the down payment you're gonna
move slow and do it with a whole lot of
peace and a whole lot of wisdom and
you're gonna ignore all those other
voices you're free Joanna you're free
congratulations congratulations this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
what's going on this is the Ramsey Show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I know you're driving there and you
have a question about your marriage you
have a question about your mental health
you get a question about your money
getting out of debt
make the call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go out to
Eliza in Raleigh North Carolina what's
up Eliza
hi thanks for taking my call of course
thanks for calling what's happening
so
um I got married in January gross do you
like him
I do like him all right
um
so my husband and I are going through
Financial Peace University right now
um and
um we're about halfway through
um he's not sold on the
1 000 emergency fund he thinks we need a
three thousand dollar emergency fund and
like I don't see that big of a
difference between the two
um and so I'm like is this something
that I should fight him on is my
question how much money do you guys have
right now
well we have lots of money from our
wedding so we just
um put a bunch of it towards our
um well my student loans
um but in the bank we we had the three
thousand dollar emergency fund plus like
I don't know like maybe two thousand
dollars for expenses right now okay so
you have about five thousand bucks to
your name how much debt do you have
um well we we did just pay off a bunch
so now it's um about a 190
000. most of it is student loans what's
the other types
um and then it's his truck loan which
he's
um working on selling his truck right
now cool so that'll clear some debts
Eliza you married well good job
what's the household income thank you
um we are
right now about 120 000. okay so let's
play this out you have a three thousand
dollar emergency fund because he wants
it the HVAC goes out it's six grand
what happens now
it's not enough right
right and so the point of the thousand
dollar emergency fund was never to cover
the emergencies because 1500 is not
enough two thousand three thousand is
not enough we know that the point of it
is to light a fire under you to get out
of debt faster because you are not safe
with 190 000 worth of debt whether you
have a thousand bucks in the bank or
three thousand or ten thousand
there is no safety until we get to debt
Freedom when somebody says hey I freaks
me out to only have a thousand dollars
we say good
or I won't be able to sleep if all I
have is a thousand dollars in the bank
good
because you are running for your life
because one sideways thing and you're
gonna lose everything that's that's the
point it's the point is you know that's
what gazelle intensity is there's a lion
chasing you trying to kill you that's a
debt
that so the sentiment we totally get it
and Eliza I mean I'm with your husband I
I mean that the thought of only having a
thousand dollars that's that feels
insane to me I totally get it totally
get it he's not crazy
it's just like George said it's the
light of Fire
it'll make you do things like sell a
truck even though you love that truck so
much right he does love that truck so
what caused him to go sell the truck
um well we talked about it a few times
and then eventually it was his idea so
yeah
so that's what you need to get to like a
great wife let's get the thousand dollar
emergency fund to be his idea and then
he'll be like oh my gosh I talked to him
a few times suddenly it was his idea
well done Eliza that's outstanding but
yeah you guys said you're going through
Financial Peace University
yeah we're about halfway through right
now nice and it's not quite clicking
with him yet
he's hung up on the thousand bucks
yeah I I mean I haven't like really
brought it up more than a couple times I
kind of have Let It Go but I think
that's a good point that you made that
it's is it supposed to be scary it is
how soon if y'all mapped out like if you
really just get be in Nas about this how
how how long is going to take you to pay
it off
yeah I think um what were calculated at
like three or four years right now but I
um am hopefully very soon getting a big
increase
um I'm leaving a residency and starting
a real job
um as a veterinarian so I was gonna say
what yeah you ran up some bills so this
is going to be the real deal Holyfield
you're gonna make some good money huh
right yes excellent so think about this
this is what we say if you have an
emergency that's over a thousand dollars
here's what you do you pause the baby
steps you continue making minimum
payments and you cash flow the expense
making a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars could you cash flow a two
thousand dollar emergency an emergency
in a given month
absolutely yeah and that lets me sleep
at night I go oh okay I guess we're fine
after all now if there was a forty
thousand dollar emergency we wouldn't be
able to cover that anyways so make sure
you have good insurance in place across
the board homeowners Auto Health all
those things to avoid uh the big ones
but for the ankle biters realistically
when people follow our plan they go oh
yeah it was those little 200 emergencies
that were getting us so Eliza are you
gonna open up a shingle or are you going
to go work for with a group
um so
so working for it
oh I literally had an issue
yes I had an issue with one of my
chickens I didn't know you you all exist
poultry vets yes that's incredible
yeah so I want to be
um a commercial poultry vet so basically
I'd be the one making sure that the the
chicken or the turkey that you're eating
is has a good life and then is safe for
you to eat
God bless a lot you just restored my
faith in humanity and it was growing
very thin way to go Eliza so hey here's
the thing though can I can I do we make
me a promise
yes you're gonna get the salary and it's
gonna double if not more
and your colleagues who have similar
jobs are going to be driving way nicer
cars than you
and they are going to say what are you
doing
if you can hold the line and continue to
run through the baby steps continue to
get out of debt when you get this
increase the return on those few years
that you were just had to hang your head
and your colleagues were like what are
you doing and your clients were like
that that looks like an o4 Camry and
you're like that's what I'm talking
about right if you can hold the line
there you are setting you and your
husband up for a completely transformed
family tree but I want you to know it's
gonna be it's gonna be hard you're gonna
be driving and it's gonna be hot and
you're gonna be going to some turkey
farm and you're gonna be in a bad mood
and your car is going to your air
conditioner is gonna break and you're
just gonna be like I make too much money
to be hang in there do you promise
I promise we did it that's a win John
that's a huge huge win so this is
interesting you guys did this awesome
labor crisis event and one of the
speakers on there was Michael Easter of
the Comfort crisis and I just keep
thinking with a thousand dollar
emergency fund everyone wants to be
comfortable like I'd just be more
comfortable if I had three thousand
dollars yet I'm okay having a hundred
thousand dollars in debt with uh 1500
payments coming out my ears but ah John
they emerge I just we're so scared of
being uncomfortable when it comes to
doing the hard things and the right
things it uncomfortable doing the the
right thing right and I think it all
started from a good place we all learned
we got more technology and we were able
to be a little more comfortable and a
little more comfortable and I love
leather seats and cars and I really love
air conditioning but all of a sudden
when we begin to solve for Comfort
anything uncomfortable became bad and
something we had to fix not something
that was good that we had to head into
right because it makes us stronger on
the back end it solves generational
issues if we do a couple of years of
discomfort right Michael Easter's book
The Comfort crisis it's a masterpiece
everybody should have in their Library I
read it and I I gave it to my 12 year
old son the next day and I was like this
is your next book he's like oh come on
dad nope you will read this book
actually he was 11. I need to read it
it's been it's been on the list because
here's the thing I've got the copy of my
you can borrow mine my wife and I did a
getaway we had a heated tile floors in
the bathroom of this getaway John and I
went back home and stepped on my cold
tile floor and I was like oh it's so
uncomfortable and I went oh my gosh I'm
the worst person I'm gonna give you that
book before the day is over George
before the day is over hey that's
another hour in the books I want to
thank the gang in the booth and George
and his heated tile floors listen
America build a non-anxious life pay off
your debts get connected give recklessly
and seek peace we'll be back soon
thank you
do you love a good Dave Rand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your money
your relationships your mental health
your life I'm John deloney joined here
by George Campbell and we're taking your
calls on everything whatever you got
going on your life and you need some
help to know what to do the next right
thing we got you triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and I know there are people driving
their car right now and something just
popped into your head
something going on with your mental
health something going on with your kids
at school something going on with your
spouse something going on with your
money give us a call Triple eight eight
two five five two two five we'll change
your name we'll change the the state
you're calling from will protect your
identity best we can but give us a shout
because I promise you whatever you're
experiencing whatever questions you have
other people millions of other people
are experiencing that same thing so your
bravery can help other people
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to Shawna in Vancouver
what is up Shawna how we doing
hi John hi George I'm so nervous hey we
are super nervous too
especially George because I'm
uncomfortable I'm so scared exactly
you're safe here you're good you're safe
you're safe here what's up Shawna okay
so
um
my husband and I we never separated but
he left nine years ago
um my one daughter got a brain tumor my
other one was diagnosed with uh type 1
diabetes and the house was a bit
stressful
so he left but he was involved and stuff
he he didn't live too far from us and
it's been nine years and
um
we had a discussion about us getting
back together
and moving back into our house and
staying in separate rooms while we build
our relationship and one of the
um one of my main things because we
fought about money so much was he had to
do Financial Peace University with me
which has been two months and still
hasn't and bought a 70 000 truck and I
just paid my car off
and I'm feeling super resentful
and
um like there's no you can't have a
conversation because he thinks it
personally like he's being attacked
so I'm just wondering
what to do
Sean I can I can hear it in your voice
know this George and I are heartbroken
with you
this is hard
um I can hear it in your voice you know
exactly what's happening
because you have been on this exact
roller coaster before right
[Music]
and for whatever reason whatever story
he told whatever picture he painted
nine years later you're exhausted
you've been creating a warm
sustainable home for two kids who are
going through hell or four kids two of
which are going through it all
and then he waltzes back in my guess is
his lease ran up or he lost a job but
that's a whole other conversation for
you and I he didn't lose the job but he
did need a place to stay yeah that's
exactly right so it's his idea to say
Hey what if we tried to make things work
and I well it was it was both of our
idea like he was he was changed like a
different person and I mean my kids are
all adults ish now I've got two
graduating this year and they were like
super excited and then once he moved in
and we set up boundaries because I'm a
big firm believer in boundaries now I
wasn't in the past
uh he took it very personally and
basically doesn't speak to us and we we
did have a very peaceful poem and I have
my own business that I run with my older
daughter and we do very well he needs to
go
and you know and you know that
tell me if I'm wrong he violated the
promise I'm coming to you
you're not wrong
so if you're calling for permission
yes a little but listen
here's the part you can't skip over that
you've skipped over for 10 years
you have to intentionally enter into a
season of grief
for the husband that gave you four kids
and when it got hard he quit
and after you did a decade
of back-breaking work
he waltzed back in and you said hey this
time
it's going to be different because this
is my house now and this is the family
that I have held together
and this is the the young kids that are
now adults that I have had to raise
mostly on my own they got to come play
at your house but I raised them
so here's my boundaries and he's like
because he's a toddler in an adult body
and then you said hey this is really
important to me
and this is a condition of you coming
back into this house
and he said okay and then he spit on
that conviction with a seventy thousand
dollar truck
yeah that's about it
it is and let me tell you I'm
heartbroken for you he's not on the
phone so I'm not gonna talk bad about
him anymore I'm sad for you
because you let your heart believe again
and it got hurt again by the same guy
right
right I'm so sorry
Shawna the thing is he's a really good
actor and he's going to convince you
that I know I made a mistake but honey
this time it's going to be different I'm
willing to do whatever it takes I want
to be there and then he's going to let
you down again and he's going to violate
your next promise and so right now
there's no way to build trust when he's
proven himself to be untrustworthy with
a pattern of behavior
right and so you need to say you gotta
go
and I don't know if this is ever going
to work but right now for sure it's not
this is going to be a brutal
conversation with your kids I know that
because they have a picture that Mom and
Dad were always going to get back
together and your husband probably told
them for the last three of my kids that
have been like
are they done
yeah wow look at hey Mama you raised
your kids right you raised your kids
right because I have four amazing
children yeah here's what I really want
you to do okay
um
two things number one I want you to
reach out to my friends at betterhelp
okay you can go to betterhelp.com
deloney and they'll give you a discount
I want you to talk to a licensed
counselor because you've been through a
lot the last decade and this is hard and
it's exhausting and it's lonely
the second thing I want you to do is to
reach out to one or two girlfriends in
your area do you have a couple of
friends that you trust with everything I
do I have I had only good friends okay
would you take them out because again
George and I are two Knuckleheads on a
radio show okay on a podcast and so it's
easy for us to lob grenades we're
getting one side of a story all that
stuff
I want you guys to help me get through
my day I just want you to know that well
you help our will you help us get
through our day so we're grateful but
listen I want you to take those
girlfriends out you buy the coffee in
the bagels I want you to tell them all
that you're experiencing all you've gone
through the last year
each of them what what do I do next
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your pass change your future
the my number one best-selling book
about almost this exact moment how do
you deal with the past and ask yourself
that haunting question what do I do now
and it gives you a path forward thank
you so much for the call this is the
Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
taking your calls on money your mental
health life whatever you got going on
give us a shout triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's run out to
Chicago and talk to Joshua what's up
Joshua
hey what's going on man how you doing
we're partying what are you up to no not
a whole lot I I feel for Shawna the last
time and I feel smart it hurts doesn't
it hurts especially with the uh you're a
you're a man of integrity and it's hard
to hear somebody get treated like that
isn't it damn right yes I just want to
say thanks to all you guys at this show
appreciate you listen you guys do for
anything to do for everyone around this
country
I appreciate you I'm grateful my brother
I'm grateful how can we help you man
okay I gotta I gotta live with a pickle
man I got um
my wife
been married for 17 years
we've got four kids
we bought a whole nine years ago in
Granger Indiana
right well
the septic should never have been passed
okay
on the inspection
yeah all right my brother-in-law is a
septic Guru that's what he does he works
for safe septic and let's go a plug out
there
um
it's never a past
but it happens he says it happens all
the time they pass it
for about a year however either way that
that ship is sailed we try to contact
the health inspector we had six months
and you know had I known then I'm 40
years old had I known men what I know
now I've done a little more digging
Okay so we've
it's done the subject is done 100
percent
all right uh what's it gonna cost to get
a new septic system 50 to 60.
there's going to be about 30 probably 25
30 000 okay that's nice all right okay
but that's a deep cut that's taken six
feet of Earth the entire length of my
field system out with x amount of dump
trucks and bringing that same amount
back with gravel sand blah blah that's
right and you got to collapse the other
system at the at the front
there's an option of putting it in my
front yard which is my baby I mean I've
worked hard I couldn't fix my grass
that's my baby I love my grass Joshua
come on all right man in his grass so
what's your question my baby yeah so
what's up
question is don't take out a loan to do
this is that if that's what you're going
to ask that's my question I think should
I reach
a challenge sure
my home which makes no sense I
I'm unlocked in at four we bought it
years ago
well it makes no sense for a whole lot
of reasons the interest rate is just one
of the smaller ones for me they're
stupid right now so yeah Democrats I
mean I get it but yeah I I can
like a HELOC if I did a HELOC because I
don't have that cash on hand we've been
throwing so much money at the house how
much money do you have right now
yes
yeah I mean liquid cash to your name
things you could sell whatever
okay do you have any other debt other
than the mortgage no sir well we have we
have my my truck I only owe four
thousand on that I bought it two and a
half years ago we've been triple payment
what would the truck sell for today
oh shh probably 25 000.
ta-da now you can go to the bathroom in
peace
you're not gonna sell that truck I know
Josh
I love my truck like we worked so I've
been blessed I know but you love your
grass and your truck and pretty soon
You're Gonna Love not going to the
bathroom indoors
family more than you love the truck I've
got a promotion at work I'm making
excellent money how much you make what's
your salary
well for this
yeah I make 100 15 000 a Year Josh hey
if you ever hang your head on 115 Grand
I am blessed the Lord has blessed me
that's that's that's amazing Joshua can
the septic system wait two months
that's my question too okay
you're a financial math guy okay I'm
good at math but okay let's say
if if it's my my brother-in-law can pump
my septic I basically have an 1100
gallon tank in my backyard that's it
with no function so two months it's full
so if I did two months at 260 a pump
that's 130 a month
if I just wrote that out for a couple
years and just started stacking cash
away with that couple of years dude I'm
talking about having this thing paid for
in cash within a few months which means
you're living off of nothing we're
selling everything that's not tied down
and we're getting done with this but but
isn't that's my question does it make
more
maybe pinch it no here's what that's a
funny thing that you said referring to
your septic system number one you get by
with what you can do until you have the
cash to pay for it in full that's it I
would pump it for two months a maximum
of three
and I would take that 11 Grand and we
would stop paying 50 uh 50x on my truck
stop paying extra on the mortgage stop
going out to eat for three months and I
would scrounge together another 10 grand
which you can do on your salary
we're putting together here okay I work
in the RV business okay
okay it's a very bad time to be in
manufacturing because of the Democrats
okay it's very very listen Joshua how
long are we going to blame the Democrats
for a freaking septic system oh well I
am always going to I am concerned about
blaming listen to me you sell the truck
for 25 you owe four on it correct
that's 21k you get a beater truck and
with the rest you add to your 11k you
have a new septic system next week and
then you save up for the next three to
five months and buy yourself another
truck ta-da you can poop in peace the
Democrats have nothing to do with this
listen I have a potential two-month
hey that's actually Fair that's fair
I'll give you that I'll give you no
orders so then what do I do if I spend
my eleven thousand dollars to my name
I might not be able to watch Food okay
but brother listen if that two months
turns into five and you've put your
house on the Block for a septic tank
they're gonna take everything
true okay I I don't do this very very
good okay I got okay now I think you are
right to be worried I am worried because
I don't know where my next it's great
and then hold on listen listen
I know but what you're doing is very
common I've done it too when I get
anxious about one thing I put all my
energy and start making wild decisions
about other things
okay the thing I can't control in my
life it scares me I just start running
and trying to find other things I can
control and I can sign up for this I can
get this I can double down on this I can
move this dead over here to this thing
and I create a chaotic mess and
interestingly I make my anxiety
infinitely worse
if I'm you and I'm staring at a 60-day
I'm making no dollars
my life is shutting down financially
potentially 250 days I mean it could be
sure so here's what I'm doing and then
I'm getting the job tomorrow
the industry is completely done right
now okay then get out of that industry
if Dave came in here and said hey we're
not getting any more radio ads y'all are
gonna get paid for the next two to six
months I wouldn't work here man I'd be
at the Apple Store
you know around here at 17 an hour
somewhere you know what I mean like you
know what it is you know what that's 17
an hour more than you're gonna make
sure yeah I know listen here's the deal
here's what I know for certain the data
tells me that job loss
the body experience is job loss the same
as losing a loved one
and I want you to reckon with the fear
and being scared
and then I want you to remember this
phrase facts are your friends
I will not put my house on the Block for
what might be a six-month issue I won't
I won't put my family in that kind of in
that kind of disorder I'll go work a job
that is way beneath what I think I'm
worth
because I'm that kind of guy well I tell
my kids that I know let them hey don't
tell them anything let them watch it I
Shield I Shield them from all the
scariness of my industry right don't
don't Shield them sit them down and say
things are really scary so dad's gonna
have to do some different stuff don't
Shield them don't lie to them show them
things got really scary and here's what
I'm gonna do next that's a gift
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Taran in Phoenix what is up Taryn
how we doing
so good how are you
doing good excellent what's up
so I have an issue I guess with my mom
and our relationship right now I
currently live with her and I'm 20 years
old going on 20 this year and I'm also
in school I'll be moving to Georgia to
go on campus in August and so as of
right now like I said I'm living with my
mom and occasionally I do help pay some
of the bills like the internet or
occasionally her phone bill because
right now she is out of a job my issue
is she gave me a letter yesterday
stating how she is upset that I don't
contribute more financially even though
I don't make that much money and she's
wanting me to contribute to the rent the
issue is she's wanting me to use my
credit cards that I don't use anymore
but she's aware of the credit limit and
so she's like well why don't you just
use them and I'll pay you back but I
feel very uncomfortable doing that and
she's upset that I'm uncomfortable doing
that so I don't know what to do because
she's needing help to pay the rent this
month so I don't know what to do in this
situation yeah do you have a job Taryn I
do where do you work I worked at a
dialysis center okay
um so do you have money in a checking
account somewhere or savings account are
you saving all that money for tuition
what where's that money going I
hidings you know I use the budgeting app
that you guys use
um and most of that money is going
towards me moving to Georgia since I am
moving across the country by myself
and some of it will be going towards
like my tuition for August because I'll
be needing to come out of pocket for
that excellent
um so that's where the money is going
and I just don't want to dip into that
because you know I'm gonna need it in
less than two months yeah of course
um Why can't your mom get a job
um she's in the medical field okay and
you know out of preference she just
doesn't want to get the covet shot and a
lot of the jobs are requiring that
um so they're not accepting her because
she's not getting the shot which I
understand because I don't have it but
it's not required for myself so well I
I'm all about standing on principles and
values 100 but when we stand on
principles and values they often come
with consequences right
and so a byproduct of that consequence
is now she doesn't have any money
but she comes up as an excuse that's
right that's that's what I was getting
at Taryn yeah so here's the thing
anytime a 20 year old or an 18 19 anyway
I'm all about
living with your parents for x amount of
time for x amount of Reason six months
after college to get you launched up
fine
um through college to help cover costs
because tuition's expensive and
housing's expensive fine no problem but
you have to be very clear on the front
end here is the arrangements here's what
I'm going to charge you for rent or for
bills or here's my expectations when it
comes to a curfew whatever because it's
Mom and Dad's house they can do whatever
they want to right so and then you have
to decide whether I want to abide by
those arrangements right what I don't
like about this is Mom is changing
Midstream and not only is she changing
Midstream she's making you the the
villain here
yeah and to go off of what you just said
um I am going into my junior year
sometime fall so I was going to move a
lot earlier to Georgia but she said well
why don't you you know just do school
online right now and you can stay home
for free basically that way you can save
up so like you said she is changing that
point and now I'm in a position where
it's like I feel like I have to make a
hasty move and I don't want to do that
and end up putting myself into a
situation that I can't get myself out of
that's not don't ever think that
you can get yourself out of any
situation if you don't go down to
Georgia and sign a 24-month lease on an
apartment you can't afford right that's
then you're trapping yourself but
here's the thing I want you to take Mom
out of the equation
it's not by your hand but it's in your
lap you didn't mean for this to happen
you didn't plan for it to happen mom
just wrote you a letter she didn't even
give you the courtesy of giving you an
in-person conversation she wrote you a
letter and sat it down and blamed you
for I can't believe you're not doing
this I can't believe you're not doing
this here's the thing credit cards
aren't real you don't have that money
now you might if I'm you here's honestly
probably what I would do is here's
several hundred bucks for rent this
month I'm moving out and I would take
some of that money out of savings and
that's that's probably what I would do
but you have no obligation to do that
you do have a choice to make she is now
as your landlord said here's the the
deal for living in my house
you can a meet that deal or B move out
those are your two choices and I would
not linger and fight and lose a lot of
sleep over what about this and why not
she's laid it down she gave it to you in
writing right so cool that's my two
choices are you gonna be heartbroken
yeah is it was it your plan no but this
is reality you didn't plan it you just
dropped in your lap now you have to do
adult things and decide what you're
gonna do if you have a friend that you
could crash with for a month or two
before August
um
a couple of friends you could crash with
in Georgia and just say hey can I give
you a couple hundred bucks and I think
so I
um given that I do have money in my
savings there is like I found a room
that I was going to sleep at anyways for
school um for like 800 a month but she's
also needing last month's rent so I need
1600 and she needs 1600 now not you no
not for my mom at the new room oh okay
um so you might need to stick it out
another month or two but here's what I
would do cut up the cars and close the
account because then she has no reason
to say well you can just go into debt
and say no this money's allocated my
money in savings I need for moving I
need for tuition and I refuse to go into
debt to cover bills that we had no
communication about previous to this and
let's let's I want to take um like with
the covet shot let's take some of the
drama out of this out of the and let's
let's come let's make it a more Simple
Story let's say she was a house framer
and she said I'm not using hammers
anymore I'm not picking up a hammer
great don't pick up a hammer you can't
do that job anymore right because the
job says you have to have this tool to
do this job
you can get all mad you can fight it you
can get angry you can burn you can do
all that stuff but when it comes down to
it they have said a tool for this job is
this a requirement for this job is this
so she has said I am not doing this
thing
so she is opting out of the medical
profession fine
she needs to go find a job and that is
her responsibility to pay for her bills
and here's what I want you to keep in
your heart choose guilt over resentment
every time
because if you just start writing checks
and running up credit cards and you're
having to pay them off while also being
a student while also trying to work
while also trying to get internships and
do all that stuff in your last two years
of college
you're no longer going to feel guilty
about what's going on you're going to
start to resent your mom and I don't
want that for either of you
so draw your boundaries and say here's
what I can do here's what I will do
here's what I'm going to do and then
you're going to feel guilty no matter
what you do
choose guilt over resentment every time
and I didn't make that up that's from
Brittany brown or somebody
regardless it's a great truth to live by
okay okay and listen the next few weeks
the next few months they're going to be
hard relationally they're going to be
hard moving what just understand this is
going to be difficult there's not an
easy path forward here so I'm going to
do the right thing for me in this season
okay okay
I'm sorry that's happening to you that
breaks my heart for you
it's tough yeah and parents listen if
you want to help out your kids awesome
I'm all for it
you are not helping out your kids your
adult kids
by entering into new relationships with
them landlord-tenant relationships and
not clearly laying out the rules they
are not nine and ten anymore they're
adults they're college kids
so you gotta lay out here's my
expectations here's the rules for this
this this new living Arrangement are you
in you got to do it up front and you're
the adult you're the landlord so you go
first this is the Ramsay show we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Applause]
today's scripture of the day is
Colossians 4 6. let your speech always
be with Grace as though seasoned with
salt
so that you know how you should respond
to each person
Austin I feel like you picked that for
me because my speech is not always
seasoned with Grace so thanks for
kicking me while I'm down appreciate
that the great Stevie Nicks says your
graciousness is what carries you it
isn't how old you are how young you are
how beautiful you are or how short your
skirt is
what it is is what comes out of your
heart if you are gracious you have won
the game
all right let's go out to Ivan in Dallas
Texas what's up Ivan
it's for Camel and Dr Delaney thanks for
taking my call of course man what's up
um I'm pretty sure I know the answer to
this
today for a long time yeah
proverbial slap in the face We're not
gonna hit you no we're gonna do this
Bible verse it says speak with Grace so
go try that out
thank you bless you
so I do have
locked up in crypto
and it's down almost 50 percent I was
gonna say was it originally 21 or was it
42 and now New York 42. it was 42 yikes
it was 42. what is it in a single crypto
coin or what
uh most of it is Bitcoin ethereum
okay
so you chose the good coins and they
still are down 47 okay correct touches
so you made a smart dumb decision good
job Ivan correct okay yep so what's your
question
um
so my question is
I feel like I shoot cash all that payoff
that ten thousand dollars that I have
left on the car loan and
put the rest I guess in its emergency
fund invested how much money do you have
liquid
liquid uh probably like
4 000
okay so if you sold all your crypto for
21 today you'd pay off the car loan
you'd have 11 left add it to your fourth
that gives you a fifteen thousand dollar
emergency fund
and no debt correct
plus uh fifty uh five hundred dollars
that
a month that I didn't have before
because of the car loan payment
correct man that sounds like freedom to
me
the part we have to grieve is the stupid
tax we went oh my gosh I can't believe I
lost 20 grand on crypto I know right and
that's the hard part truthfully like I I
feel that and the possibility it goes
back up and you're going to be debt free
oh nobody anything and it's gonna go
back to its original value as part of a
roller coaster and you're gonna go I
should have right no and all your
buddies who are gonna go dude you should
have hung on man bitcoin's up 80 100
right and you're gonna have to go I know
but I'm also debt free and I have an
emergency fund and I'm investing in
different ways now and I'm fine with
that can I can I ask you a personal
question Ivan yes I feel like I can hear
it
in your soul coming through your
exhausted Dallas voice
like you're tired of writing this
particular ride is that fair I am have
been one day I wake up and I say should
I I'm gonna rip this Bandit off today
and the next thing I'm saying is uh I
went to December and I'll I'll see what
it was at has it consumed your life in
some way where you're constantly looking
at the phone watching it go up and down
24 7.
um
really so
it's not all because I have a good in
common you know I cash flow everything I
pay every more cash have you been
investing in other ways
yes I have my 401k I have a independent
Roth IRA and
you know guys it's you know pulling all
the advice this was just what's your
what's your income what do you make
[Music]
uh before or after child support
okay after
after growth is about a hundred and two
thousand a year okay
if I'm in your shoes for the next year
or two I'm gonna stick to my 401k and my
IRAs and I'm going to just live with
some peace in my life and start to save
up for some goals I have and use cash
and once you're there if you still want
to get into crypto a year or two from
now with some fun money outside of your
15 for retirement go for it
right but still get rid of the crypto
right now I would be selling a man I'd
be debt free tomorrow with an emergency
fund because right now you are not safe
you have one emergency and you're back
to going further into debt
yeah yeah with an extra 500 bucks coming
in every month if you if you get rid of
this Carl yeah you get a six thousand
dollar a year raise
that is true which can go to the Roth or
yeah this is the this is the best Roi on
a phone call you've ever made hey and
make no mistake you are locking in
what 26 or 27 000 of losses is that
right
correct you're locking them in so in
fact I'll tell you George and I I I'm
not gonna I don't want to be responsible
for that like I I'm gonna tell you what
I would do is I would I would choose
Freedom here I would solve for freedom
but you're locking these losses in
you are but man if you wake up on Monday
and you don't owe anybody anything
you don't have a truck payment it's just
I'm telling you man your life's just
gonna feel different
yeah plus you don't have that nagging in
your brain about what secrets are doing
today and hey if you do sell will you
make a commitment to your soul to not
check on crypto prices for six weeks
I promise that it's like breaking up
with a girlfriend and then you go back
and check her out on Facebook and and
and text her and don't call the ex okay
just be done
yeah and don't answer the text from the
the crypto blog
yeah trust me you might need to find a
new friend group because they're going
to be nagging you for years about this
going remember the time dude you sold it
for who cares exactly and if they're
really your friends if crypto explodes
and they all buy airplanes they'll take
you on their trips anyway that's right
so there you go
all right it's time George for the
George and John Telethon that's right
this is very exciting if you haven't
heard we're doing something around here
we've never done before all of the
Ramsay personalities are leading
Financial Peace University including
John and I and John's class starts it's
coming up John yours starts May the 22nd
and uh this is nine videos nine lessons
but we're doing it like a boot camp in
four or five weeks so meeting twice a
week John's class is meeting virtually
Mondays and Thursdays 1 p.m eastern time
my class starts June 20th we'll be
meeting at 12 30 Eastern Time p.m
Tuesdays and Thursdays and we are pumped
about this you're gonna learn everything
you need to know about how to handle
money how to pay off debt how to build
wealth all of it we're going to be your
personal cheerleaders through this class
with a whole bunch of other people
joining and this is the way I look at it
it's kind of like group Financial
coaching and you get to meet nine times
for like 79 bucks yes if you did One
Financial coaching session one-on-one it
would be like 200 bucks yeah so this is
a steal hanging out with us virtually
over Zoom from the comfort of your home
and if you want to join us fpu.com is
the place to go and this is the stuff
that changed my life John back in 2013
when I started here I went through
Financial Peace University I had a whole
paradigm shift I realized the system is
designed to keep you broke I realize
it's all my fault but it's also my
responsibility and I realized that I
could actually Buck this system and get
out of the Matrix and find Freedom and
Financial Peace on the other side and
here is our plea
Jade warshaw and Rachel Cruz are
destroying us when it comes to class
sizes
help your brothers out you can't let the
ladies win on this one
me George kin
Eddie
let's be honest these are gonna be
amazing classes George
I I don't want to join yours just to see
how I might join yours as well that
would be fun we should do a little pop
in on each other's class
yes but you gotta be nice to me if you
pop out I'll be nice so here's the deal
you watch the videos before we meet we
meet up for a group discussion we're
going to do interactive q a uh which is
like you know getting on the Ramsay show
without having to fight thousands of
callers at once so it's a great
opportunity and if you've been thinking
about it like I think I should join this
is your key
don't think anymore just jump in you
will not regret it all right I want to
thank Zach is that Andrew back there
James Joe Austin Christian the whole
gang
you guys crush it you're the best in the
business I want to thank the mighty
George Campbell good show today good
times I want to thank you America listen
build a non-anxious life pay off your
debts get connected to a community give
recklessly and seek peace cut out the
drama we'll see you soon
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]